it has been one of the hardest hit
cities in ukraine to the point they're
now burying the dead in mariupol
anywhere they can it is surrounded there
are russian troops on three sides of the
port city russian ships on the other
the regional governor says the attacks
and airstrikes are constant
sunday the russian defense ministry
demanded ukrainian forces in the city
surrender it said if they laid down
their weapons and raised white flags
russia would give safe passage for
soldiers to leave mariupol the general
who made that offer didn't say what
would happen if it was rejected and it
was the city's mayor declined the offer
posting on facebook that russia didn't
need to give them time to decide their
answer was ready in advance the
country's deputy prime minister said
they wouldn't even talk about surrender
or laying down weapons
the reports in russian media of what
might happen if russian forces do take
over quoting defense officials they say
ukrainian authorities in mariupol could
face a military tribunal for siding with
what they call bandits
ukrainian president meantime says some
civilians in mariupol were able to leave
the city sunday about 4 000 people were
able to get out through humanitarian
corridors their plans to send more buses
back today but the city is also trying
to determine the losses after a russian
bomb was dropped on an art school crane
says about 400 people were using it as a
shelter vladimir zelinski is calling the
situation in the city a terror that will
be remembered for centuries
mike armstrong global news jeshof poland